so you might remember that a couple of
weeks ago Michael Bloomberg ran these
fat pic ads of Donald Trump where it was
an ad about Trump's golfing where
Michael Bloomberg said something along
lines of you know the only thing I would
hire trunk or I wouldn't even hire Trump
to run a golf course something like that
but the visuals during that short ad
were these very very unappealing
pictures of Donald Trump in a very light
colored golf uniform where he looks very
heavy and Trump likely as clinically
obese as as many of you know and Trump
was immediately just completely
triggered by Mike Bloomberg repeatedly
tweeting about mini Mike when that
happened two weeks ago very very much
paying attention to what Michael
Bloomberg is doing and triggered by it
and Trump actually came up with a pretty
funny line in response to those ads
where he said that Mike Bloomberg mini
Mike is negotiating being allowed to
stand on a box if he makes it into the
debates which is really funny I mean I
think that Donald Trump's tweeting could
not be less presidential and
embarrassing to the country but every
once in a while he comes up with
something funny like Bloomberg is trying
to negotiate being allowed to stand on a
box and Michael Bloomberg has continued
to focus his ads on attacking Donald
Trump in a way that triggers Trump and
it's working Trump tweeting more attacks
on Bloomberg over the last day tweeting
about Michael Bloomberg's height quote
mini Mike is a 5 foot 4 inch mass of
dead energy who does not want to be on
the debate stage with these professional
politicians no boxes please he hates
crazy Bernie and will with enough money
possibly stop him Bernie's people will
go nuts now Bloomberg is actually 5 foot
8 that's a very respectable height
particularly if you look at my driver's
license not 5 4 but in all seriousness
attacking a candidate's height that's
where Donald Trump has been relegated to
at this point why do you think Trump is
so easily triggered and flabbergasted by
what Michael Bloomberg does is it that
Bloomberg is just so much richer than
Trump and from hates that is it that
Bloomberg was able to express his
disdain for minorities in that unearthed
audio in a much more eloquent sounding
way than Donald Trump has talked about
you know rapists and
from Mexico or whatever I don't know
what it is but Bloomberg is triggering
Trump Trump going on to tweet along with
a photoshopped picture of Bloomberg's
head on what seems like a little kids
body this is the President of the United
States folks saying quote mini Mike
Bloomberg is a loser who has money but
can't debate and has zero presence you
will see he reminds me of a tiny version
of Jeb low-energy Bush but Jeb has more
political skill and has treated the
black community Capital B for black much
better than mini capital M for many I I
shouldn't like this so much but this is
like a guilty pleasure Trump's tweets
about mini Mike Bloomberg and the clear
rage and disdain that he has for
Bloomberg are just delightful so let me
know what you think is Trump being
triggered because Bloomberg has more
money because Bloomberg made his money
with the Bloomberg terminal instead of
inheriting it from his dad is it that
Bloomberg hasn't gone bankrupt multiple
times at the bit in his business is the
way Donald Trump has I am NOT a
Bloomberg supporter as you all know but
I find Bloomberg's rise in the polls
absolutely fascinating and I find the
degree and ease with which Bloomberg is
able to trigger Donald Trump and the way
that it's playing out absolutely and
completely hilarious let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman why
is Trump so triggered by Bloomberg and
then later in the show I am going to
address this issue of is Bloomberg an
oligarch what does that term mean and is
it a relevant term in the United States
relative to other countries there was a
big dust-up on nemesi I think it was on
MSNBC maybe it was CNN who knows I don't
watch any of them about the term
oligarch being applied to Michael
Bloomberg recently we will talk about
that in audience questions your calls
are upcoming and of course I want to
hear from you on Twitter at D Pakman
follow me there and let me know what you
think about trump's trigger ability at
the hands of Michael Bloomberg one of
our sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
you go to david pakman.com slash watch
don't pay thousands of dollars for a
high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of inch
arrows watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a cronograph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high-quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch